all right nikki
yes nikki oh were you from originally
where'd you grow up uh i grew up in the
suburbs of chicago
which ones
hinsdale darien lyell west chicago
downers grove yeah tell me about your uh
family growing up
um family life uh grew up mostly as the
only child
and i have step sisters and half sisters
parents were not
together um weren't ever married
a little bit kind of crazy i guess
how would you describe your childhood in
general
um
it was fun
but definitely a little bit crazy no no
abuse definitely a lot of abuse yes all
kinds
so definitely had um
sexual abuse and a lot of verbal abuse
what other kinds of abuse are is there
physical yeah there was definitely some
of that is probably many more that we
haven't a lot of it was more of just
what i seem to not as like the stuff
that was done me didn't affect me as
much as
what you saw yeah i feel like because
you as a child you you know do what you
see like mimic what you see for sure
how far did you go in school
graduated high school i didn't walk
though they wouldn't let me walk
why is that uh because i changed school
so many times i didn't have enough
credits oddly enough oh but you gotta
you got a degree i did yes
and what have you done what have you
done for work
uh mostly sex work so i started out as a
dancer um i was 18.
used my cousins was i 17
i think i was 17 and used my cousin's id
to like get in the strip club
so that was very uh
eye-opening to me as a stripper yes
and honestly i think the first night
that i worked i was with a girlfriend
and they wouldn't let me work like that
first night in the club so i sat on bar
stools
and just like talked to patrons all
night and drank
and didn't do one dance but i made like
something like eight hundred dollars
and i remember the next morning i was
like
i was like oh my god i want to do this
forever
so that was kind of just like
eye-opening i was like this is something
i could do because i
all i was doing was flirting with guys
and they were giving you money for what
yeah
that night [ __ ] um
i think i literally didn't get my ass
off the barstool so i was just flirting
with guys and talking to them and you
would tell them but i really need money
for rent i need money for whatnot no
that first night i literally just sat
there like oh i'm gonna work here
tomorrow i'm gonna work here tomorrow
and they're like okay
they pull out their wallets yeah and at
that place there was no poll it was like
you dance on bar stools
so even when i did work when i go went
back to work there um it was very easy
you like
walked around with your drink talking to
people and
you like did little lap dances on the
bar stool for twenty dollars
so it was like so you learned quickly
that yeah it was very easy it was money
for yes
and then um
let's see i went there that was off
manheim and then i went to
heavenly bodies
that was bad
don't ever work at heavenly bodies
there's different calibers of strip
clubs
i think they got actually busted for
like having um
like storage units full of money
because they would charge ridiculous
like i remember some nights i'd have
like fifteen hundred two thousand
dollars in my hand and because of all
the fines they'd you know find me for i
mean i can't even remember some of the
things that they would find us for that
were ridiculous
but we would leave with 45 50 bucks
knowing we had to pay 40 to walk through
the door to start our shift the next day
like
there was a burger king next door and
sometimes me and my girlfriend couldn't
even afford a meal
at burger king
because they would just fine you like
every bit of money that you made it was
crazy
so you've lived this sex worker
lifestyle
yeah it's uh but but you've told me that
you're you think you're addicted to sex
i definitely know i'm addicted to sex
i've been like that since i was very
young do you think that was because of
the sexual abuse i feel like yeah i was
forced to be sexual weight earlier or
maybe i just knew that like that's what
men wanted
i don't know like loki i've always kind
of known
this sounds terrible um loki i've always
known like since i was really young that
i was either gonna be like a porn star
or
a sex worker
or a stripper like i just kind of always
knew that that's
like i knew what men wanted so i just
knew that was what i was going to do
that sounds bad
but it's true i've always kind of known
that so
there you have kids i do i have one
daughter she's 10. and you're raising
her
i did till she was five um i found my i
left her dad
and kind of found that i was gonna go
down the same path that my mom went down
which is like living with questionable
people
and i because i was put in situations
like that bad stuff happened to me so i
just didn't really want that to happen
to her so i made her dad take her
kind of blew up in my face now i don't
really talk to her too much but i'm glad
that she's
like literally living a white picket
fence life that and protected from what
you are exactly like i might not have
the best relationship with all of them
right now but i feel like i'm
glad that she's
gonna have like a square life you know
what i mean
and eventually i feel like she'll be
happy that i didn't put her through all
that
[ __ ]
so your sexual
addiction
it affects your life personally as well
um
not just professional yeah definitely
it's hard to be in a relationship with
people i feel like i usually either
cheat or
yeah i usually end up cheating
i just can't help it
as bad as that sounds
what do you what do you think you're
looking for
um i think sex gives me a gratification
that nothing else actually gives me like
i could do drugs i could
go shopping you know what i mean like
whatever normal vices are drinking
whatever like that doesn't really do the
same as
sex i don't know
and what what is a
a wild night
for nikki look like
well since i got smarter i realized that
like instead of just [ __ ] random
people it's probably best to do it for
money so
kind of monetize that so now i'm kind of
jaded with sex a little bit
just because i know like why go [ __ ]
some random guy from tinder when i can
find someone that'll pay me 300
to do it but since i left
my ex so i think it's been like
almost three months
um
like i've been away from him and not in
a relationship with him and i haven't
done that yet so i'm pretty proud of
myself not good
broke because of it but before you
before you were working at strip clubs
you were you what did you do
um yeah before i got with my second
husband i was a full-blown like escort i
would dance occasionally but
got really bad anxiety so
i feel like it's harder for me to work
in strip clubs just because i'm not in
control of the environment or who i'm
seeing
so i really would rather
you know like escort and do videos only
fans videos private videos you're doing
all kinds of different things yeah i'm
just a jack of all trades
i kind of fell into that by accident
though because when i moved to las vegas
uh when i left my first husband i
didn't you know my daughter went with
her dad
and i was just living a totally
different lifestyle from obviously what
it is here in chicago so people were
like okay well you're at the pool with
crazy [ __ ] like i want to see more
let me see more and that just kind of
turned into like the
uh the what was it the snapchat premium
and then
like that turned into only fans so
for young ladies that are thinking of
trying to make money with their bodies
what's the most lucrative
avenue
i mean it kind of depends on who your
fans are because i mean only fans is
great
but now that everyone does it
it's kind you know what i mean it's kind
of like guys are always about uh why
would i pay for porn when i could get it
for free
but if taylor swift had a page
of her nudity you would want to see you
know what i mean but only if you were a
fan of her if you didn't like her then
you wouldn't really care
so only fans like hit or miss but i mean
definitely there's always people that
want to see what you have
and i feel like when you have
personality on top of looks too like i'm
a total [ __ ] but
everyone says i have
personality no but i can see that you
guys like your personality i don't know
why but
yeah
what was your father like
um
i definitely have daddy issues we'll
just put that out there
he was a hard ass uh he was in jail
when he was younger and stuff so
i feel like that's why i usually tend to
like hard-ass guys that are
like felons
you know
yeah but when i was younger he was a
total skinhead
kind of racist
um
yeah we don't really have a relationship
anymore but when i was growing up he was
definitely scary
very scary
and do you find yourself attracted to
scary guys
actually
i was uh let's see this was about four
years ago
i was on the phone talking to a prisoner
who i met through a friend that i was
talking to and i seen this guy walk up
and i was like oh my god he looks like a
[ __ ] killer like that's what i want
fast forward to two months later he
literally killed my neighbor he's in
prison
for murder shout out to flacco
like
did i make that happen because i said he
looks like a killer i don't know but
like that's what i'm attracted to if you
have neck tattoos in a prior
priors i usually i have bad taste in men
that's probably why i've been divorced
or i'm you know on to my second divorce
so
but you've been in love i think i've
been in lust i don't i don't know if
i've really ever been in love can i take
a sip of my belly of course
yeah i don't
so a romantic relationship with you
looks like
sex is the main focus and then i love
you i think because i have good sex with
you but then you end up cheating
not even always me but usually yeah
something like that have or i get very
bored
or we fight
are you adhd
i get so bored so easily i need to be
constantly entertained
constantly but i mean
if i'm with somebody that's an exciting
person
what's been the best part of your life
um it's hard to say there's so many
i don't know i think just um every
weekend
no not even just i my life goes like
this you know like i'll go through like
the deepest darkest depression and then
good things will happen
um i think just my ability to like
connect with people i feel like i'm
low-key an empath
so um
yeah so you have moments where you make
a good connection yeah
and i think that's a lot of why i'm
addicted to sex too is because you know
when you [ __ ] somebody
i could swear right okay when you [ __ ]
somebody like that connection that you
get you know what i mean like
i don't know
you could you could have sex with 100
girls literally 100 girls but no one
will do what i do for you know what i
mean like
just that's
i don't know because it makes the world
go around yeah and i find power in that
i guess a little bit too knowing that
what i do
in the bedroom is how like that's how i
that's what he called my love language
and you're very confident
am i
well you're telling me that you're
i don't know
i just feel like yeah like that's i like
that connection that i have with people
and
when i was escorting and i learned that
when i was dancing too just um a lot of
people that do come into the strip club
or that do come seeking escorts aren't
even looking for sex like you could
literally find a girl that'll [ __ ] you
at the bar girls are you know no offense
women some girls are
will do anything um
so it's not really hard or tender you
know i mean sex is sex everyone can find
it but um
finding someone that actually listened
to you and give you that like that
connection like it kind of made me feel
a little bit like i was doing nurse duty
you know what i mean i'm bringing
there's lame guys i'll be like look at
me in marching band with my mom
you know like obviously they don't have
many friends and he was very excited to
show me his marching band but like just
the fact that i would watch and be like
oh wow
you're
you know oh that's awesome
you know what i mean like he needed
somebody to do that even if i'm
not really that interested but obviously
he's interested so i just feel like
being interested in what he's interested
for that 20 minutes made him happy but
what have you learned about men from
this
life you've lived
how old are you 33 33.
um i've learned a lot about men um
mostly that they're i mean you guys are
pretty simple and i don't mean that in a
derogatory way it's just like you just
want your basic
you know what i mean i hate to call you
cavemen but you just want your basic
needs met
and that's easy for me i'm
i'm like a nurturer so
i feel like i like doing that even if
it's for 40 minutes you know like i like
caring for people and making them feel
good that makes me feel good
what's been the lowest point of your
life
it might be right now
yeah um
just because yeah i uh was doing really
well before i got married kind of just
gave up my whole life
for a guy like i call myself a little
mermaid i gave my voice up for a man
um yeah i just kind of gave up
everything for that guy
and left with a suitcase
i was uh he was pretty abusive he did
abuse a lot of drugs
where'd you move to uh we moved to genoa
which is kind of near rockford kind of
near sycamore
like north northern yeah it's kind of
out in the country a lot of people from
genoa college of nowhere
but yeah we moved out there and
i just tried to be like a good wife
and he loved every
excuse me he loved everything about me
up until a certain point and then like
hated everything about me
you know like the only fans thing and
that men love me and did he know that
yes
he knew everything so
what emotions do you go through you get
depressed or very much so that's why
it's super hard being sober right now
too just because um you know obviously
like drugs numb
what what drugs what were your favorites
i got a lot of favorites uh i stick to
the m's so i like marijuana and i like
mushrooms um for a while i dabbled in
meth for a while um
i feel like that's still of my drug of
choice but it's not available to me
right now so i probably won't do it so i
can
get it
but is what does meth do to you
sexually i've heard stories everything
it's great i can
i mean
normally i don't want to like take a
dick in my ass you know but on math like
[ __ ] i might
so yeah
and also
when i was full-blown escorting or
dancing in the club and stuff um
you know most of the guys i seen weren't
sexy
i mean i've probably only seen 20 sexy
customers in my life
so it helps
make me
you know is that the reality of a sex
worker is that the majority of the guys
you're interacting with are just not
most of them aren't attractive and it
doesn't even mean that they're not good
in bed because i've seen like ugly ass
dudes with big fat ass dicks that make
me come quick as [ __ ]
but
yeah um most of them aren't but there's
a few that i've been super attracted to
and even had like a little bit of
like relationships with
i like all the people that i meet
that's one thing too i feel like
i like that's great the you know even if
they're not always the best of
caliber you can find something desirable
or yeah about anybody i meet really
interesting people all the time and it's
funny like
throughout the walks of life how those
people like kind of come back into your
life and
is there any shame for you in this
life you're leading
now that my daughter's 10 um
i just would never want her to be
ashamed of me but uh she grew in my body
so i would pretty much 98 sure that she
would just know that like
people have to do what they got i mean i
would hope that she would understand
that but i mean
to each their own you know i don't blame
people if they're
you know not understanding of my
lifestyle or what i've had to do but
people love to be judgmental i mean yeah
like i just got a text yesterday someone
was like
you [ __ ] ass ho is this nikki i'm like
who pardoned who's this they're like
don't act like you're proper
and i called the phone number and like
no one answered so it's just like people
love to talk [ __ ] but no one i would
just send that person my address
like come get some but
i love the hate because obviously you're
sitting there watching
so and i mean i've had to do what i've
had to do and i
like wouldn't change anything because i
feel like that wouldn't make me
yeah well to me it all boils down to
what you went through as a young girl
yeah i feel like definitely erase that
and i think you your story looks very
different yeah i've
i don't ever really think about it too
much but then when i do i'm like okay
because my sister's um
i have a step sister that grew up with
me pretty closely
she didn't experience all of the same
trauma but a lot of the trauma we did go
through together
so
we're both equally kind of
[ __ ]
you know we're both you know she danced
for a long time she definitely has sex
addiction
she got she's on her fourth child
she loves hard
you know she's got anger issues heart is
crack cocaine
um probably harder
she loves really hard like
she's very loyal to those that she loves
but those that she loves are usually
shitty guys but that's the same thing
that i do you know like we're really
loyal when you say hard you mean
define heart oh like hard like loves to
the end of time oh i say because hard
means crack okay oh no in the hood she
she definitely doesn't do that i think
our parents dabbled in that though
i know i found some crack in my like you
know how people have like kitchen
utensils
i remember one morning i like walked in
and i think i was making something so i
like grabbed a spoon and i found like a
vial with like a
i was like
pretty sure this is crack so your mom
was
uh my mom was pretty good about hiding
her drug use i know she did a lot of
coke
uh she drank a lot
but my grandma was there to kind of
watch me so i never seen much of that my
dad definitely partied hard
are you would you describe yourself as
self-destructive
for sure and i like to uh sabotage
anything good
i don't i don't notice it at the time
but then like
hindsight
i definitely tend to do that
and i don't
tend to like be gravitated towards like
calm or chill people
you know you like chaos
i don't know why but yeah i think i do
like i just recently started talking to
a very nice
man who's pretty normal not a square but
kind of
and um
i could picture myself with him so much
but at the end of the day i feel like
i'm gonna ruin him like i need someone
nice that's also toxic you know what i
mean like i don't wanna
i feel like i need a troubled soul or
what's a trauma bond like i need someone
that's kind of been through similar hell
i don't want to ruin uh good people
i feel like i did that to my first
husband
what are you afraid of what do you worry
about
like all of my fears
sure
if you're if you're gonna be open which
you are um my worst fear in life is
being stabbed to death
um that happened to my grandmother
and i didn't learn about it till i was
like 17 so like i don't know why that
just scares me so much but that scares
me
so like you can do anything to me you
pull a knife on me [ __ ]
i'm i'm running
i shouldn't tell everybody my weakness
but that is my
weakness
um
i think that and just maybe living under
a bridge
being homeless yeah which is
happened maybe twice but not the living
under a bridge part
um
yeah i don't know i don't think i have
many fears i don't like heights
are you happy would you describe
yourself as happy you seem to be um
you know i'm going through a very big
life change right now so i'm just happy
that i'm not in a very toxic
relationship is is your happiness a
facade no i'm i'm deeply sad at the end
of the day
but i'm great okay no no i'm happy but
i'm grieving
you know what i mean like
i'm a happy person it's just i'm um
you're a survivor yeah i'm saying
goodbye to you know my my married life i
had to give up my dog who was my
emotional support dog when i moved into
my apartment
um
gave up like the wife life
definitely not an escort anymore drugs
i'm not doing so you know what i mean so
i'm in such a transitional place i feel
like i'm actually feeling things for the
first time so i don't even think
i'm not happy i just feel like yeah i'm
grieving and i'm feeling things
what gives your life meaning
hmm
you know
honestly i really want to get into like
um
more creative stuff like if i'm doing
content i want to start doing more
fetish content and or
funny stuff just because for so long i
have been focused on
my vagina or my boobs or my looks and i
feel like i'm so much better behind the
camera
like i love taking pictures of beautiful
women
i love
editing like when i would do my only
fans videos and stuff um i love the
editing process i love
making women feel good so i feel like i
kind of want to get
into maybe like behind the camera stuff
and i'm just so creative
and i have so many funny ideas and good
ideas for stuff so i feel like yeah i
just kind of
want to do more creative things because
that does that brings me a lot of joy
whether it's like painting or making
weird not weird uh creative only fans or
fetish content
uh i'm so old i'm not really with this
tick tock [ __ ] but i'm trying
i feel like i would be good at that but
it's just
so much work
if you had your life all over again what
would you have done differently
um i definitely would have gone to
school
like a like college or
some sort of school would that have been
hard for you as adhd yes
but
i found adderall at a young age so i
think if i could have uh
had just a little bit of support
in that aspect
i would have been good um most of the
stuff i start i don't finish like i
started beauty school and i quit
and i started nail school and i quit and
i did bars attending school in vegas and
i did it for a little bit and then i
quit
like i
i need to follow through with things you
know
like i want to do this podcast
i know it'll be great but i'm a little
bit nervous about it so yeah i was
nervous to come see each day but i did
follow through with that takes a lot of
courage to sit here
um well i don't have any shame like i
feel like most of my family already
knows i'm a train wreck
so
the only issue was you know the double
chin which you say isn't there so you
don't have a double ship
yeah i mean i'm an open book i do you
feel like you were betrayed by your
parents
i definitely am a little bitter
about that um
mainly just now i feel like you know as
a
as a parent you know you just kind of
learn stuff as you go i understand that
but as they got older they kind of got
shittier
and it makes me kind of feel like what
did i do to make you guys i mean i'm
mostly there um
i'm my mom's only child my dad has two
maybe more um
you know what i mean like why
i don't know but i i think that made me
stronger in the long run
i know people that have had it so much
worse i have a
i call her my sister i don't think she's
my blood sister but she was my stepmom's
daughter
and she's 18.
she's been through most of the stuff
i've been through at her small little
age her mom overdosed on heroin
um you know what i mean god she's had it
so much worse than me so it's like i
can't sit there and
ever be like
well with me because there's people that
have had it
way worse i think as long as you kind of
just learn
from that like if i would have had
shitty parents i probably would have
kept my daughter with me to struggle
through all of that
stuff you know and that guy that i dated
that was a murderer that i had no idea
was a murderer uh
turned out i mean i only hung out with
him for about three weeks but he was a
sex offender and i had no idea god
[ __ ] forbid
god [ __ ] forbid i would have let my
precious little angel be around it you
know what i mean like no same thing
would have happened to her that happened
to me and god knows
where that would you know so
even if i'm sad that i don't have her
with me she didn't get molested so i'm
you know what i mean like
the choices
that i make in life probably aren't the
best for a child right now so i'm glad
that
she didn't have to struggle through that
because
i would tell my ex all the time don't
do this with me don't do this with me
don't do this with me because
that affected me as a child seeing kind
of my parents put me through the
you know push and shove of people that
aren't married and kind of deal with
co-parenting
he didn't really understand that his
parents are beautifully still married
you know and have a great relationship
so he didn't really have to go through
that people who have not been through
some of the things you've been through
or some of the other stories on my
channel
they
it's easy for them to judge because they
don't understand what it's like to come
from felt it yeah and i bless their
hearts because ignorance is bliss like i
like that they've lived a charmed life
but you haven't been through poverty or
terrible child abuse yeah or having no
options no no no role models no nothing
it's really hard to think about
how
people with uh
blessed lives think you know what i mean
like because i always think of like the
darkest deepest bad thing that could
happen being that that's usually what
happened
but if i was to be a privileged person
for half of my life and then these
things happen as an adult oh my god i
don't know how i would cope actually you
know what i mean like i feel like those
are the
those are the people that almost commit
suicide most of the time i feel like
because they just don't know what to do
and i've been there but
luckily
usually i've been through something
worse so i always kind of like bounce
back i feel like do you have other
addictions other than sex um
i i feel like i have a low key addiction
to money i love shopping
sex is definitely my biggest one um
yeah i mean i do love drugs i love i
like drinking
gambling
i did live in vegas for a while so
gambling is really fun but i think
because i had addict parents
i kind of pump the brakes on everything
but i think since i have so many vices
and you know what i mean i feel like
um
like for example if i'm not doing meth
i'm overeating if i'm not over smoking
and over drinking
i'm over you know what i mean i'm over
sex you know what i mean i've always got
to have like maybe like two or three
indulgences yeah
what would you say is the
most important lesson you've learned in
your life
um you're the only person that can have
your back
like
at the end of the day it doesn't matter
if you're the richest kim kardashian
or the lowest
whatever the lowest thing is um at the
end of the day like you can't rely on
anybody you have to i mean if you can
great but you you shouldn't like you
have to rely on yourself and be strong
i don't know i feel like that's the
leveling up you know just be strong and
always try to do better
i don't know all right nikki thank you
definitely the best lesson it's a great
lesson
nikki thank you so much for sharing your
story thank you for having the courage
to share it well thank you for having me
you're amazing
thank you very much no problem
you